what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here I'm John Humphrey video 3 John is
now warming up more to Justice League
I'm nine percent more excited he's not
as strongly hesitant still in the
hesitant territory I'm gonna be hesitant
until halfway through these clips have
been making me enjoy like really looking
forward to the film even more now
because I like the pacing of the scenes
we're still getting there here's what
I'll say thus far having seen a couple
clips today I am already expecting that
I will enjoy sitting in the theater a
lot more than I did for the prefer BBS
and Suicide Squad at the very least I
think this is gonna be a million times
better than that overrated crap fest
Wonder Woman Batman meets Aquaman let's
get to it okay here we go I'm building
an alliance every time he was assembling
a team he comes on the king tide that
was last night
they wanna help t those pesky let's do
those icebergs in the harbor for months
and so I should go through well this
stranger
there are enemies coming from far away I
need warriors I'm building an alliance
defend ourselves all right cool you know
what I'm loving about these clips
all right we're seeing that he interacts
with the team differently depending on
who they are sure that like he talks as
a very specific type of way when he's
talking with flash he's young he looks
more frightful yeah that he has a very
specific way of interacting with black
yeah an Aquaman he's like no I got it I
gotta play tough guy yeah I got I got
talk some [ __ ] right yeah I did yeah and
I'm most I'm most skeptical about the
Aquaman character from the previous
trailers cuz he just looks like he's
just so excited to be yeah fighting
all-out destruction but III really
enjoyed this scene actually and I
enjoyed their interplay together even
though most of it is in Jason Momoa
space yeah expressions it's pretty
obvious who when you look at the hair
this is the only dude with eyes who look
anything like that big he looks like a
sea man an American or something
speaking English to you at the very
least yeah yeah yeah I didn't know how
there was a question there but yeah that
was anyone when they're talking up
against the wall and you know Bruce is
trying to kind of you know cracked a
little wise yeah I was like finally some
personality for Bruce I like how he's
kind of telling the tale of the Aquaman
in the beginning yeah you could you know
cuz you know a guy like that is gonna
you know want to distinguish himself at
some point yeah if he's got to keep his
cover down yeah and Bruce is gonna look
for those tails yeah and I
like that moment when new he's like that
was last night yeah I did come on he's a
good Clips it's not they've been
watching like action Clips I mean we're
going to but I know what you've been
wanting or scenes show you some scenes
right now yeah yeah this is definitely
softening my view of this movie and I
don't expect the worst so much yeah I
least expect that this will be a
pleasant yeah because the dialogue
scenes are looking enjoyable the
dialogue scenes are looking cool and I'm
like I'm enjoying seeing the different
dynamics this really is a Batman led
film and with Batman interacting with
Gordon Batman interacting with flashback
narrative of Aquaman he he interacts
with them differently and I appreciate
that the writing took the time out to do
that with these guys yeah yeah yeah for
sure and and you know to see that
writing come to life a little bit in the
clip like this is good yeah see what the
characterization cuz Aquaman it's been
so long for Aquaman to get to the big
screen Aquaman is a pretty notable
character and like you know they made
that parody trailer on on Entourage yeah
you know and so I've been curious
especially just to see who this guy is
that wasn't a parody trailer that was a
kick-ass trailer was it yeah Vinnie
chase got cast played Aquaman in James
Cameron's movie I never actually saw it
oh dude I wish James Cameron's directing
Aquaman sounds like a jury oh my god
it's so love of water alright guys well
hey you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow us on social media we're gonna
check out another another couple Clips
here